It's good to be here. I have nothing. It turned out I thought that I had an open. Will thought he had a nice... Well, let's weigh in. But this isn't... No, but this is it. Yeah, this is it.
在这里感觉真好。我什么也没有。原来我还以为我有一个空档。威尔觉得他有一个很好的……嗯，我们来权衡一下。但这并不是……不，但这正是。是的，这就是。
Welcome to the process. We're podcasting right now. We've got absolutely nothing. By the way, this is the... We've got Bennett and Rob and Michael. Everybody say hi. Hi. Yeah. We've got the whole, all of us.
欢迎来到这个流程。我们现在正在录播客。我们绝对什么都没有。顺便说一句，这是……我们有班尼特、罗布和迈克尔。大家打个招呼。嗨。是的。我们全员都在，我们所有人都到了。
Like a party in your ears. And we're trying to think of a way to start the show here before we get into the funny music. Let's take some calls. Let's take some calls. Let's take some calls. Yeah. Something to fix some suggestions.
就像在你耳朵里开派对。在我们加入搞笑音乐之前，我们正想办法怎么开始这个节目。我们接几个电话吧。我们接几个电话吧。接几个电话吧。好的。提供一些建议。
Let's pick up that line from Des Moines. That's on line three. Call or welcome to Smart List. What's your question? I just want to know how old you guys are. Okay, I am... Why did you go fuck yourself? Okay, we lost that caller. We're picking up, oh, from Denton, Texas on line five. Good morning. Good morning. I love it when you talk about food. Good morning. Good morning. I love it when you talk about food.
我们接听一下得梅因打来的那条线。那是三号线。来电者，欢迎来到Smartless。你的问题是什么？我只想知道你们多大了。好吧，我……你为什么不去吃屎呢？好吧，我们失去了那个电话。我们接听，哦，来自德克萨斯州丹顿的五号线。早上好。早上好。我喜欢你谈论食物的时候。早上好。早上好。我喜欢你谈论食物的时候。
Yes. Pfft. Pfft. Welcome to SmartLess. Smart. Lass. Smart. Lass.
是的。噗。噗。欢迎来到SmartLess。Smart。Lass。Smart。Lass。
Smart. Lass. Hi guys. Hi, guys. I think that this is our first chat and giggle of 2024. Well, we don't want to date the episode, but yes. Well, but I mean, for us personally, we want the listener, don't listen to this part, but I think, hey, Sean, this is our first of the year, isn't it?
Smart。Lass。嗨，伙计们。嗨，伙计们。我想这是我们2024年的第一次闲聊和嬉闹。好吧，我们不想给这期节目定具体日期，但是是的。好吧，但我的意思是，对我们个人而言，我们希望听众——别听这部分，不过我想，嘿，肖恩，这是我们今年的第一次，对吧？
Yeah. Yeah. It's nice. Happy new year, guys I think, hey, Sean Will, this is our first of the year, isn't it? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's nice. Happy New Year, guys. Oh, happy New Year. You guys look a full year older. Wait, what? Nothing. What did you guys do?
是的。是的。真好。新年快乐，伙计们。我想，嘿，肖恩、威尔，这是我们今年的第一次，对吧？是的，是的。是的，那很好。新年快乐，伙计们。哦，新年快乐。你们看起来老了整整一岁。等等，什么？没什么。你们都做什么了？
How was your New Year? Will took a lesson in social, socialism, no. Socializing. Socialization, how have you been enjoying your personal life? Shawnee, do you feel rested? I'm just getting sick, I think, unless it's allergies. I don't know. Oh, could be COVID, COVID's flying back.
新年过得怎么样？威尔上了一堂关于社、社会主义的课，不对。社交。社交化，你的个人生活过得怎么样？肖妮，你觉得休息好了吗？我想我只是生病了，除非是过敏。我不知道。哦，可能是新冠，新冠又卷土重来了。
I tested, I tested, I don't have it. You had it before, right? I had it the first time ever, a year ago, yeah. And Willie, you still haven't had it, right? No, I've never tested for it. I've never taken a test. Are you serious? No, I wouldn't mean I'm serious.
我测过了，我测过了，我没有。你以前得过，对吧？我一年前得过一次，这也是我有生以来第一次，对吧。威利，你还是没得过，对吧？没有，我从来没检测过。我从来没测过。你是认真的吗？不，我不是认真的。
Of course, I'm taking a million tests. No, I've never tested positive. I've been, I've had the flu, but I've never tested positive. But I'm like, remember the summer we thought that maybe I had it? Yes. When you guys were out in Long Island, JB.
当然，我做过上百万次检测了。不，我从来没有呈阳性。我得过流感，但我从来没有呈阳性。但我记得，还记得那个夏天，我们以为我可能得了新冠吗？是的。当时你们在长岛，JB。
I love Long Island. Wait, who was I just talking to? Somebody at the Globes the other night who has got a fancy house out in the Hamptons pretty close to yours and they're like, oh boy, every time I hear a net call it Long Island. Long Island, yeah. Try and keep it real.
我喜欢长岛。等等，我刚才在跟谁说话？前几天晚上在金球奖上遇到一个人，他在汉普顿有一栋很别致的房子，离你的很近，他们说，哦天哪，每次我听到网民管它叫“Long Island（长岛）”。Long Island，是的。尽量保持真实。
Listen, Will, just admit it. You're doing real well. You've got a big ass summer house. You got six cars. You've got a bunch of gold bonds down in the Seychelles. You got six bicycles. I'm telling you this, I think so. Last summer of the summer before I was pulling
听着，威尔，承认吧。你现在过得真不错。你有一栋超大的避暑别墅。你有六辆车。你在塞舌尔有一大堆金边债券。你有六辆自行车。我跟你说，我觉得是这样。去年夏天或前年夏天，我正开着车驶入
into the SAG Harbor and I was in my GMC pickup. It says Sierra 84X, by the way. Okay. Don't drop down. Don't drop down. And you're trying to keep it real by saying you're driving a pickup truck, but let's be clear, it was a freebie
萨格港，当时我开着我的GMC皮卡。顺便说一句，那是一辆Sierra AT4X。好吧。别泄气。别泄气。你试图通过说你开的是一辆皮卡来保持真实，但我们要搞清楚，那是一辆免费赠送的车，
because you are the voice of GMC. Well, it's been over 25 years. It's been over 25 years that I've been the voice of GMC drugs featuring the GMC Sierra with the six function multi-pro tailgate. So anyway, this guy comes up to me as I'm putting Danny in his car saying, oh, you really do have a GMC. And I go, what man?
因为你是GMC的代言人。好吧，已经超过25年了。我担任GMC汽车代言人已经超过25年了，主打带有六功能多功能尾门的GMC Sierra。所以不管怎样，当我把丹尼抱进车里时，这个人朝我走过来，说：“哦，你真的有一辆GMC啊。”我说：“什么情况，老兄？”
I don't know the guy's little stranger. It was pretty absurd. But, Jason. Wait, Sean, so you think that you're getting sick? I do. I had an endoscopy yesterday You know what is that? Is that you had a colonoscopy yesterday? No endoscopy. Is that above the belt or below the belt? That's above the belt So I don't know if my throat is sore because there's something shoved down and or of course Careful careful with the jokes right now. It's very early in the show
我不认识那家伙，他是个完全的陌生人。这挺荒谬的。不过，杰森。等等，肖恩，所以你觉得自己生病了？是的。我昨天做了胃镜检查。你知道那是什么吗？那是你昨天做了肠镜检查吗？不是，是胃镜。那是腰部以上还是腰部以下？那是腰部以上。所以我不知道我喉咙痛是因为有什么东西被塞下去了，还是因为……当然，现在说话小心点。节目才刚开始一会儿呢。
No, Sean's talking about going to a place where he paid money to have somebody stick something down his throat. And then he got an endoscopy. By the way, I can't even believe I walked right in. He sure did. Hey, so that's what he said. What did this fella tell you was the problem? And he claimed he was a doctor. Did you check his credentials? By the way, he's the best doctor in the world. Dr. Tray's Cedars. Oh, here we go. And wait and Jay's gonna love this
不，肖恩说的是他花钱去一个地方，让别人把东西塞进他的喉咙里。然后他做了一个胃镜检查。顺便说一句，我简直不敢相信我就这么自投罗网了。他确实是。嘿，所以他是这么说的。这个家伙跟你说问题出在哪里了吗？而且他声称自己是个医生。你核实过他的资质吗？顺便说一句，他是世界上最好的医生。锡达斯的特雷医生。哦，来啦。等等，杰一定会喜欢这个的
I had my and oh, where's my invisible? Oh, let's wait for your invisible. Funny. It's it's hard to find the invisible You should just paint a stripe on it Stop losing it. Don't put in your invisible line for the for the podcast thing. No, I have to, I have to keep it wearing. No, you don't. So, no, I do, I have to keep it on. He's gonna wear it all the time. So, it's gonna do the same thing. Anyway, so his name is Dr. Trayzon.
我做了……哦，我的隐形牙套呢？哦，等一下你的隐形牙套。真搞笑。很难找到那个隐形牙套。你真应该在上面画条纹。别再弄丢了。别为了播客节目把你的隐形牙套放……不，我必须戴着。不，你不需要。所以，不，我必须戴。他打算一直戴着它。所以，它会起同样的作用。不管怎样，所以他的名字叫特雷森医生。
And I said, he goes, do you have anything? Madeleine, you do you have anything, blah, blah, blah. You're all good. I said, no, I just have my plastic, you know, teeth lining thing. I guess you could say I have my trays on. Oh my God. Yeah, that's really good.
我说，他问，你有什么问题吗？玛德琳，你有什么问题吗，巴拉巴拉。你一切都好。我说，没有，我只有我的塑料牙齿矫正器什么的。我想你可以说我有我的“特雷森（牙套谐音）”。哦，天哪。是的，这真的很搞笑。
Did he think you were flirting? No, no, no. No, but he was so sick of me making jokes. I just made bad joke after bad joke. And I was sitting there, have you had an endoscopy with the thing down your throat? Yeah. I did it at the same time that I got my colonoscopy.
他以为你在调情吗？不，不，不。不，但他对我的玩笑感到厌烦了。我只是一个接一个地开着烂玩笑。我坐在那里，你做过插着管子的胃镜检查吗？是的。我做肠镜检查的时候顺便做了。
Yeah, so they put you like, I did. Yeah, you did it. They used the same tool. They used the same tool. Yeah. Are they offering you like I did yeah, you're the same to use the same to Are they offering a twofer right now it's the best time to do it you might as well you're already out It's the devil lies in the sequencing. You'd really want to do the endoscopy first. Is that correct? I guess I mean I don't think it but I but I said so I had this thing They make you bite down on this thing and your mouth to keep your mouth open, right?
是的，所以他们让你像——我做了。是的，你做了。他们用了同一个工具。他们用了同一个工具。是的。他们现在有提供买一送一的优惠吗？这是做的最佳时机，你反正已经麻醉了魔鬼就在于顺序。你真的想先做胃镜，对吧？我想——我觉得不会，但我——但我说，所以我做了这个。他们让你咬住嘴里的这个东西，好让你的嘴张开，对吧？
So I had this thing, they make you bite down on this thing and your mouth to keep your mouth open, right? Sure. And so they can stick the camera down there. And so I'm sitting on my side with pillows, with, you know, in a gown with this thing. And I said, bad joke after bad joke, I go, I haven't been like this since college or something like that.
所以我有了这个东西，他们让你咬住嘴里的这个东西来保持嘴巴张开，对吧？当然。这样他们就能把摄像头伸进去了。所以我侧躺在枕头上，穿着病号服，戴着这个东西。然后我一个接一个地开着烂玩笑，我说，我从大学以来就没这样过或者类似的话。
And he goes way in the back of the room, he goes, yeah, we're probably gonna wanna stop talking for a little bit. Yeah, he's had it with you. He's totally had it with me. He's the best doctor. He's gonna get that propofol. He's like double the propofol.
然后他在房间的最里面说，是的，我们可能想闭嘴一会儿了。是的，他受够你了。他彻底受够我了。他是最好的医生。他要用那个丙泊酚了。他就像是把丙泊酚的剂量加倍了。
Let's get this guy under. The best doctor. How good is that? How the great is that when you wake up from that propofol? Oh my God. That little twilight? I've never felt so good in my life. Yeah, I get real chippy.
让这家伙睡过去吧。最好的医生。从那场丙泊酚麻醉中醒来的时候，那种感觉有多棒？哦，天哪。那种微醺的迷糊状态？我感觉我这辈子从来没这么好过。是的，我变得挺活跃的。
I got a bunch of jokes for the doctor. Yeah, that's what I'm saying. I can't stop cracking jokes. You feel, but the thing is, you come out of that thing and you feel light, you haven't eaten for 24 hours. Right. And you feel rested. You've just had a 45 hour long nap.
我给医生准备了一堆笑话。是的，这就是我要说的。我停不下来讲笑话。你感觉，但问题是，你从那里面出来时感觉很轻松，你已经24小时没吃东西了。没错。而且你觉得休息好了。你刚刚睡了一个45小时长的大觉。
Like the, to quote somebody, the likes of which have never been seen. Oh boy. No. Yeah, and then we, oh God, okay, sorry. Okay, that's it. 10 minutes of pattern. Let's please get to our guest today.
就像——借用某人的话说，这是“前所未见的”。哦，天哪。不。是的，然后我们，哦天哪，好吧，抱歉。好吧，就这样。10分钟的闲扯。请让我们进入今天的嘉宾环节吧。
You fucking wrote down 10 minutes of pattern too. No, I just looked up there. 10 minutes of pattern. Today we have with us a seasoned, Talk to people. We have a seasoned, we have a seasoned veteran of the industry. Oh.
你他妈的也写了“10分钟闲扯”。不，我刚抬头看了一眼。10分钟闲扯。今天和我们在一起的是一位经验丰富的，和大家聊聊。我们有一位经验丰富的老兵，我们有一位行业内的资深老兵。哦。
But she's not old. Uh-oh. She has an Ivy League education with a degree in psychology. But she's not old. Uh-oh. She has an Ivy League education with a degree in psychology, but she's never practiced. Oh, God. She is incredibly funny and can light up a room with her smile and her warmth,
但她并不老。哦哦。她拥有常春藤盟校学历和心理学学位。但她并不老。哦哦。她拥有常春藤盟校学历和心理学学位，但她从未从业过。哦，天哪。她极其有趣，她的微笑和温暖能点亮整个房间，
but she's known as one of our best dramatic actors. She's been a major movie star for over 30 years, but it has always been second to her interest in academics and activism. She's got an Academy Award, couple couple of globes, countless nominations. She can even explain the Middle East to you or sell you some perfume. And Sean, she can even swing a lightsaber. Gang. Wow. What?
但她作为我们最优秀的剧情片演员之一而闻名。她做了一三十多年的好莱坞大明星，但这始终排在她的学术兴趣和激进主义之后。她获得过奥斯卡奖、好几个金球奖以及无数次提名。她甚至可以向你解释中东局势，或者向你推销香水。而且肖恩，她甚至还会挥舞光剑。各位。哇。什么？
Oh, Natalie Portman. What? Got it. No, Natalie. I knew it. Good morning. I knew it. Wow. Oh my God, you guys. Yeah. Literally as I revealed myself, Hi! Wow. Oh my god, you guys. Yeah? Literally as I revealed myself, I got a thing on my computer that says low battery. You're gonna plug it in, girl.
哦，娜塔莉·波特曼。什么？猜对了。不，娜塔莉。我早就知道了. 早安。我早就知道了。哇。哦，天哪，伙计们。是的。就在我自报家门的时候，嗨！哇。哦，天哪，伙计们。对吧？就在我自报家门的时候，我的电脑上弹出一个提示，说电量低。你得把它插上电，姑娘。
It's gonna flip soon. Yeah, one minute. Excuse me. One minute she's grabbing for the record. Oh yeah, go get it. All right, so Sean, here's a little, okay guys, Sean, okay. You better watch it on the Star Wars stuff.
它马上就要关机了。对，一分钟。不好意思。一分钟她就要去拿充电器了。哦，对，去拿吧。好吧，肖恩，这里有一个小——好吧，伙计们，肖恩，好吧。你在《星球大战》的事情上最好小心点。
She doesn't wanna talk about Star Wars, okay? You go to the Star Trek. I got a shit want to talk about Star Wars, okay? You don't say Star Trek, does that work around? I got a shit for giving you shit with the Adam Driver episode, but now I'm... And keep Scotty out of this fucking interview, all right? And don't start going like, Scotty's got a question for you from down deep. She's put on her headphones.
她不想谈论《星球大战》，好吧？你去聊《星际迷航》。我真该死地想聊聊《星球大战》，好吧？你别说《星际迷航》，行得通吗？因为你在亚当·德赖弗那一期节目里找我麻烦，我本来有一肚子火，但现在我……还有，把斯科蒂排除在这个他妈的采访之外，好吗？别开始说什么“斯科蒂有个问题要问你，来自灵魂深处”。她把耳机戴上了。
To the planet Trigulan actually has. Tight knob, you're not coming back. Come on, come on, tight knob. Hi, Ali. Hi. Look who's back. Are you all plugged in? We weren't talking about you. I'm gonna do a whole move.
其实特里古兰星上确实有。扎紧点，你回不来了。来吧，来吧，扎紧点。嗨，艾莉。嗨。看谁回来了。你插好电了吗？我们刚才没在谈论你。我要做个大动作了。
We're changing the background. Oh, it's so pretty. What we're exposing here is a very nice zoom rare. She's created the house. Yeah, you got a nice flare going. Beautiful flare coming in. We lost her. And we've lost connection. All right. All right, stand by each other.
我们在换背景。哦，太漂亮了。我们这里暴露的是一个非常漂亮的变焦光晕。她自己搭的房子。是的，你弄了个很漂亮的镜头光晕。美丽的光晕进来了。我们失去她了。我们断开连接了。好吧。好吧，大家稍等。
Good till there, as Jason would say, good till there. That was great. Good till there. Every time, by the way, every time we're under rest of development, we'd go, and action, and somebody would go up and go, like right as we started, Jason would always go, good till there.
到那儿为止都很好，正如杰森所说，到那儿为止都很好。那太棒了。到那儿为止都很好。每次，顺便说一句，每次我们在拍《发展受阻》时，我们都会说，“开始！”然后有人会走过去说，就在我们刚开始的时候，杰森总是会说，“到那儿为止都很好。”
Good till there. Never did it. Robbie, right as we started, just would always go, good till there. Good till there. Good till there. Never did it. Robbie, we lost her on. Yeah, yeah. That's probably the battery just, so it's gonna be a second guys. The battery just, yeah, battery just cut.
到那儿为止都很好。从来没演好过。罗比，就在我们刚开始的时候，总会说，“到那儿为止都很好。”到那儿为止都很好。到那儿为止都很好。从来没演好过。罗比，我们跟她断开连接了。对，对。那可能是电池刚没电了，所以需要一会儿，伙计们。电池刚没电了，对，电池刚断电。
If you want to keep chatting, you can, but we're probably gonna need her walk her through tech, so. All right, we're back. Do you hear us, Natalie? I do. Oh, we do too. One last thing, it sounds a little bit more echoey in this room.
如果你想继续闲聊，你可以，但我们可能需要指导她重新连上科技设备，所以。好吧，我们回来了。你听得到我们说话吗，娜塔莉？听得到。哦，我们也听到了。最后一件事，这个房间里听起来回音好像有点大。
Do you mind just pulling the mic a little closer, maybe just a little higher if you have like some books on the desk to put it on? All right, is that better? I'm really sorry, y'all. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no just like driving over a canyon and hear you right back. Oh, Natalie. Hello there. Hi, Bateman.
你介意把麦克风拉近一点吗，如果桌上有书的话，也许可以把它垫高一点？好吧，这样好点了吗？我真的很抱歉，大家。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不就像开车驶过峡谷然后马上就能听到你的声音。哦，娜塔莉。你好呀。嗨，贝特曼。
Good morning. Oh, I love you called the Bateman. Yeah, well, you know, we've worked together so we can do last names. I can even go her slag, you know? Have you? Good memory with you. We did a movie in which we had the same hairdo.
早安。哦，我喜欢你叫我贝特曼。好吧，你知道的，我们合作过，所以我们可以直呼姓氏。我甚至可以叫你她的艺名，你知道吗？是吗？你记忆力真好。我们一起拍过一部电影，在片中我们留着同样的发型。
Oh my God, that's right. So this was a family movie called Mr. Magorium's Wonder Emporium. Oh yes god. That's right. So this was this was this was a family movie called Mr. Magorium's Wonder Emporium. Oh yes. It came out. Did you really? Yeah. It was a great script. Zach Helm. What a writer. It was a good script. Yeah. And Dustin Hoffman was in it. We had a great time with him. We were in where were we? In Toronto. Toronto. In Toronto. That's the same thing. Right Will? Vancouver, Toronto. Kind of the same. How dare you say Vancouver, Toronto. That's the same thing right will Vancouver Toronto's kind of the same how dare you say Toronto same thing. How fucking dare you kidding not kidding the people of Toronto loathe you Wait, wait, when did this movie come out? I forget was it 90s or 2000?
哦，天哪，没。错。所以这是一部家庭电影，叫《玛戈奇妙书店》。哦，天哪。没错。所以这是一部家庭电影，叫《玛戈奇妙书店》。哦，天哪。它上映了。真的吗？是的。那是个很棒的剧本。扎克·海姆。真是个作家。那是个好剧本。是的。达斯汀·霍夫曼也在里面。我们跟他合作得很开心。我们在哪里来着？在多伦多。多伦多。在多伦多。那不都一样吗。对吧，威尔？温哥华、多伦多。差不多都一样。你怎么能说温哥华和多伦多是一样的。对吧，威尔？温哥华和多伦多差不多都一样，你怎么敢说多伦多是一样的。你他妈怎么敢开玩笑，不开玩笑，多伦多的人恨死你了。等等，等等，这部电影是什么时候上映的？我忘了，那是90年代还是2000年代？
2000 and I'm gonna say six seven something like that boy It's just how are you with dates? Our net's just incredible with it. I swear to you, I have no, I can't tell the difference between 97 and 07. I just have no idea what's going on between the two. I'm with you. Yeah.
2000，我猜是06、07年左右吧，天哪，你对日期的概念怎么样？娜塔莉在这方面简直不可思议。我向你发誓，我完全分不清97年和07年。我根本不知道这两年之间发生了什么。我和你一样。是的。
This year, I was like, if it was 2014, I would be like, uh-huh, 2014, yeah. Natalie, where are you right now? I'm in Los Angeles. Oh, you are, okay. Very good. Yes. I didn't get to run into you the other night.
今年，我觉得如果是2014年，我也会觉得，呃——哼，2014年，是的。娜塔莉，你现在在哪里？我在洛杉矶。哦，你在，好的。很好。是的。前几天晚上我没能碰到你。
We were at the Swanky Globes. Yeah. And you were amazing up on stage with it. What about doing the presenting stuff? How do you like that? There's always some patterns, some little quippy joke you gotta do, and it's so, so stressful. I never like it. What about you?
我们在金球奖的时尚派对上。是的。你在舞台上表现得太棒了。做颁奖嘉宾感觉怎么样？你喜欢吗？总有一些套路，一些你需要讲的小笑话，这太、太有压力了。我从来都不喜欢。你呢？
I was very lucky that they didn't try and make me do anything like funny, quirky. Right. We just kind of said the nominees. Yeah, banter stuff. Because I get really uncomfortable with that. Yeah, that's the best, that's the safest way to go, because some people who try to do something that they don't feel comfortable, it shows, right? Yeah, I once had to carry Aziz Ansari out on stage at Golden Globes once, that was part of our bit.
我很幸运，他们没有试图让我做什么搞笑、古怪的事情。没错。我们只是宣读了提名者。是的，插科打诨什么的。因为我对那种事真的很不自在。是的，那是最好的、最稳妥的做法，因为有些人试图做一些他们觉得不自在的事，结果一眼就能看出来，对吧？是的，我曾在金球奖上把阿齐兹·安萨里抱上舞台，那是我们表演的一部分。
I remember what followed that, but I just remember carrying him out and literally smelling my sad card burning in my back pocket. And I just felt like, oh, that's over. There it is. What year was that, Jason? Forget it, moving on. So, so, he doesn't know. He doesn't know. Natalie Portman, my God, it's so great to have you here. That is.
我记得接下来发生了什么，但我只记得把他抱上台，字面意义上闻到了我那张悲催的手卡在我的后口袋里燃烧的味道。我当时就觉得，哦，结束了。就是这样。那是哪一年，杰森？算了，下一个。所以，所以，他不知道。他不知道。娜塔莉·波特曼，天哪，你能来这里真是太棒了。真的。
I mean, where do we even start with? Oh, I've got a series of questions if you want me to start with. I know, I've started with a lot of things. I've done some prep. The last time I saw you, Natalie, I was interviewing as the guest host of the Jimmy Kimmel show. Yes, that was great. Not so long ago.
我的意思是，我们该从哪里开始呢？哦，如果你想让我从头开始的话，我准备了一系列问题。我知道，我从很多事情开始聊。我做了一些准备。娜塔莉，我上次见你的时候，我是作为吉米·坎摩尔节目的客串主持在采访你。是的，那挺棒的。没多久前。
I know, it was like a year ago. Wait, wait, so you were the guest and Sean was the host? Yeah. Come on. Yeah. And how hard was it masking the disappointment that Jimmy wasn't there for the entire... She's got skills. She's got an award for it. It was a delight.
我知道，就像是一年前。等等，等等，所以你是嘉宾，肖恩是主持人？得了吧。是的。掩饰吉米没有全程出席的失望感有多难……她很有技巧。她为此得过奖。那太棒了。
It was wonderful. It was for Thor. And if you remember, Scotty, my husband did some bit with you in the, he was dressed as Thor in the audience. It was great. Oh, what a highlight for Natalie. Jesus Christ.
太美妙了。那是为了《雷神》。如果你还记得的话，斯科蒂，我丈夫在观众席里穿着雷神服装跟你做了一些互动。太棒了。哦，对娜塔莉来说真是个高光时刻。耶稣基督。
You were probably like, oh God, I gotta do a bit. Like, girl. I think about it often. Yeah, yeah, I'm sure. Do you remember your questions? Do you remember your questions for her, Sean, at all, yeah, I'm sure. Do you remember your questions? Do you remember your questions for her, Sean, at all? I don't.
你当时心里可能在想，哦天哪，我得演个段子。就像，天啊。我经常想起这件事。是的，是的，我确信。你还记得你的问题吗？肖恩，你还记得你问她的问题吗，是的，我确信。你还记得你的问题吗？肖恩，你还记得你问她的问题吗？我不记得了。
I was enamored. I'm enamored. I'm such a massive fan. And so many things you've done. She's good. But yeah, so it really... I think you asked me about how I got my muscles for Thor. Oh, yeah. How did you get your muscles? Tell us.
我当时被迷住了。我被迷住了。我是你的超级大粉丝。你演过那么多作品。她很厉害。但是，是的，所以它真的……我想你问过我是怎么为《雷神》练出肌肉的。哦，对。你是怎么练出肌肉的？告诉我们。
We didn't see the episode. CG. CG? No, really? No. Yeah. No get your muscles? Tell us. We didn't see the episode. CG. No, really? No. Yeah. No, I don't buy it. You tried, well, didn't you like... I worked out.
我们没看那一集。特效。特效？真的吗？没有。是的。不，我不信。你试过，好吧，你难道没有……我锻炼了。
Yeah. You didn't have Thor level. They also helped me a lot. Well, they made me 6'4", which is pretty. Or they made you 6' Thor. Great to know that that's possible. Yes. Now, that reminds me during my incredible research for this,
是的。你没有达到雷神的水平。他们也帮了我很多。好吧，他们把我变成6英尺4英寸，这相当厉害。或者他们把你变成6英尺高的雷神。很高兴知道这是可能的。是的。现在，这让我想起了我在做这方面令人难以置信的研究时，
when you did Black Swan, you went, now you studied ballet when you were a kid, but when you did like six months of training for that, I wanna say? Yeah, it was actually almost a year of training and yeah, it was really fun. Because you had to or you wanted to. Like what kind of actor are you?
当你拍《黑天鹅》时，你去了——你小时候学过芭蕾，但当你在那部电影中进行了大约六个月的训练时，我想是这样吗？是的，其实训练了将近一年，是的，真的很有趣。因为你必须这样做，还是你想这样做？你是个什么样的演员？
Do you love to do the research or do you just like to kind of wing it? I think it depends what the research is. I mean, like, I mean, if I'm lucky enough to get to work on something that I want to learn all the stuff, that's like the most fun. Like Jackie, like that was a huge responsibility.
你喜欢做研究，还是喜欢随性发挥？我想这取决于研究是什么。我的意思是，就像，如果我有幸能参演一些让我想要了解所有这些东西的项目，那这就是最有趣的部分。就像《第一夫人》一样，那是一项巨大的责任。
You had to study, study, study and make sure you got that as accurate as possible. Yeah, that's super scary. Have you played real people before? No, I'm too much of a coward. I'd say no to all of, I mean, even things that are even close. Although in air I played a real guy
你必须学习、学习、再学习，并确保尽可能做到准确。是的，这超级吓人。你以前演过真人吗？没有，我太懦弱了。我对所有这些都说不。我的意思是，即使是那些非常接近真人的角色。虽然在《爱与黑暗的故事》里我演了一个真实的人，
but no one has any tape on him. So I could just kind of do whatever I wanted to do. You do a real great impression of your uncle too, right? That nobody knows. Yeah. Including me. How do you expect, he doesn't even know who he is. How do you expect him to be another person?
但没有人保留他的任何录像带。所以我可以随心所欲地发挥。你模仿你叔叔也模仿得非常棒，对吧？没人知道的那种。是的。包括我。你怎么能指望——他甚至不知道他自己是谁。你怎么能指望他去模仿另一个人呢？
I feel like we kind of glided over that too quickly. And I know more about it. His name is John and he's a fantastic man. Remember Pete Sarifinowitz, it just made me think. Remember Pete Sarifinowitz did that thing years ago where he did 50 impressions in one under a minute and they were all of fictitious people, which is the best. We'll be right back.
我觉得我们刚才有点太快地把那个话题带过了。而且我对它了解更多。他叫约翰，是个了不起的人。我想起了皮特·塞拉菲诺维茨，这让我想起了皮特·塞拉菲诺维茨多年前做过的那件事，他在不到一分钟的时间里模仿了50个声音，而且全都是虚构的人物，这才是最棒的。我们马上回来。
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I have a lot of friends. I'm not bragging. I just do over the years. I'm a gentleman who's, I'm gonna break it here. I'm over 40. But the point is I've had a lot of friends over the years and I'm really proud of my relationships with my friends
本节目由BetterHelp赞助。我有很多朋友。我不是在吹牛。这些年来我确实有很多。我是一个……我在这里要打破常规了，我已经年过40了。但重点是，这些年来我有很多朋友，我为我和朋友们的关系感到非常自豪。
and just like anything, relationship, any kind of relationship, there are moments where it takes a little bit of work. And sometimes that requires me doing some work on myself and looking at my role in things. And that's been a really important part of my relationships, my friendships evolving and expanding and getting deeper, etc. And sometimes that takes talking to somebody else to look at my role in things. A common misconception about relationships is that they have to be easy to be right. But sometimes
就像任何事情、任何关系、任何形式的关系一样，总会有需要付出一点努力的时刻。有时这需要我对自我进行一些反思，并审视我在这些事情中所扮演的角色。这对我的人际关系、友谊的演变、扩展和深化等来说是一个非常重要的部分。有时候这需要和别人交谈来审视我在其中的角色。关于人际关系的常见误解是，它们必须轻而易举才是对的。但有时
the best ones happen when both people put in the work to make them great. Therapy can be a place to work through the challenges you face in all of your relationships, whether it's with friends or work or your significant other or anyone. I have benefited from going to therapy and doing the work and talking with somebody about my relationships. And that goes across the board. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try.
最好的关系发生在双方都付出努力使其变得伟大时。疗愈可以是一个处理你在所有关系中面临的挑战的地方，无论是与朋友、工作、你的另一半还是任何人。我从接受心理咨询、付出努力以及与他人交流我的关系中受益匪浅。这适用于方方面面。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。
It's entirely online. It's designed to be convenient and flexible and suited to your schedule. So you just, you fill out a brief questionnaire and you get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapist at any time for no additional charge. Become your own soulmate, whether you're looking for one or not. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help HELP.com slash smartlist. We get support from Car Shield. Many of you have seen the sudden rise in car parts.
它完全在网上进行。它旨在提供便利、灵活，并适合你的日程安排。所以你只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能匹配到一位有执照的治疗师，并且可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。成为你自己的灵魂伴侣，无论你是否在寻找伴侣。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜杠smartlist，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是betterhelp H-E-L-P.com斜杠smartlist。我们得到了CarShield的支持。许多人都已经看到了汽车零部件价格的突然飙升。
The last thing you want to worry about is paying double for a car repair plus the cost of labor. With car shield, customers don't have to stress about the cost of covered car parts because they offer plans that can cover up to 5,000 parts and systems. With protection plans starting at around $100 a month, car shield offers varying levels of coverage. And the best part is, most planes include coast-to-coast roadside assistance, courtesy towing, and car rental options at no extra cost. They even offer price lock guarantees so your rate will never go up no matter how many claims you file.
你最不想担心的就是为汽车维修支付双倍费用再加上人工成本。有了CarShield，客户不必为承保汽车零部件的费用感到压力，因为他们提供的计划可以覆盖多达5,000个零部件和系统。保护计划起价约为每月100美元，CarShield提供不同级别的保障。最棒的是，大多数计划都包含全国范围内的道路救援、免费拖车和租车选项，不产生额外费用。他们甚至提供价格锁定保证，无论你提出多少次理赔，你的费率永不上涨。
Protect your wallet from those high costs at a price lock guarantee rate that's locked in for as long as you cover your car. Avoid the hassle of costly car repairs with CarShield. Visit carshield.com slash smartless and save 20% today. Again, that's carshield.com slash smartless to save 20%. Visit carshield.com slash smartless to lock in your price today.
以锁定费率保护你的钱包免受高昂成本的冲击，该费率在你拥有汽车期间一直有效。通过CarShield避免高昂汽车维修费用的麻烦。访问carshield.com斜杠smartless，今天就节省20%。再次强调，网址是carshield.com斜杠smartless以节省20%。访问carshield.com斜杠smartless，今天就锁定你的价格。
Thank you to Tropical Smoothie Cafe for supporting the show. Tropical Smoothie Cafe is serving up Sunshine by the Spoonfield. They're introducing four new tropic bowls to their lineup of delicious tropical smoothies, wraps, and flatbreads. The new Tropic bowls are all made to order, topped with refreshing fruit, granola, chia seeds, and delicious honey drizzle. One bite, I'm not kidding, one bite of their new Tropic bowls
感谢Tropical Smoothie Cafe对本节目的支持。Tropical Smoothie Cafe正在用勺子为你送上阳光。他们在他们美味的热带冰沙、卷饼和扁面包系列中推出了四款全新的热带碗。新款热带碗全部都是现点现做，上面铺满了清爽的水果、格兰诺拉麦片、奇亚籽和美味的蜂蜜细雨。只需一口，我真的不是在开玩笑，只需一口他们的新款热带碗，
and you'll instantly feel like you're taking the ultimate mental vacay on a beach. And I don't use the word vacay lightly. The new Mixberry Greek Yugro Bowl is so good. It's one of those things you finish and you get in your car and you leave and you're like, do I drive back and just get one more? Because it's so good. Anyway, you might, you might do that. You might end up, so don't, maybe don't get in your car, eat it and then just stay there and save the gas because you might just go back in.
你就会立刻觉得自已正在海滩上进行终极的精神度假。我可不是随随便便用“度假”这个词的。新款混合浆果希腊酸奶碗太棒了。这是那种你吃完后，坐进车里离开，然后会想：我是不是该开车回去再买一碗？因为实在是太好吃了。不管怎样，你可能会这么做。你最后可能会这么做，所以，也许别上车了，吃完就待在那儿，还能省点油，因为你很可能会想再回去。
You're on Tropic Time now. Treat yourself with the new Tropic Bulls at your local Tropical Smoothie Cafe. And now, back to the show. I want to ask just a question about the Globes again, about the award shows in general, because you look so, I love your dress on the Golden Glow Beautiful and and do you like do you like it's a common question But do you like the dress up and this and all of that as far as globes?
你现在正处于热带时间。去你当地的Tropical Smoothie Cafe，用新款热带碗犒劳一下自己吧。现在，让我们回到节目中。我想再问一个关于金球奖的问题，关于颁奖典礼的问题，因为你看起——我太喜欢你在金球奖上的裙子了，非常漂亮，而且你喜不喜欢——这是一个常见的问题，但你喜欢盛装打扮、做这些以及所有这些，就金球奖而言？
Would you like you know what I do it, but I'd rather be home in my sweats or do you enjoy it? You know, I used to think it was kind of I used to think it was kind of oppressive and like why do women have to spend all this time discomfort and you know the men get to like roll out of bed and wear something they're warm in and like aren't you know sucking in their stomachs or whatever and now having kids I feel like it's a pretty it's pretty fun to like have people like make you feel good. And go glam. Go glam after you're just like. I don't think you own sweats.
你喜欢——你知道的，我这么做了，但我宁愿穿着运动裤待在家裡，还是你很享受？你知道，我以前觉得这有点……我以前觉得这挺压抑的，为什么女人得花这么多时间和精力忍受不舒服，你知道的，男人们就可以直接从床上爬起来，穿他们觉得暖和的衣服，而且不用收腹什么的，现在有了孩子，我觉得让人家让你感觉良好，
I own so many sweats. You do, really? Yeah, and I really kind of only wear them in real life, which has been, we moved to Paris last year and you really can't wear sweats in Paris. You do get kicked out of the country. You just get your visa taken away. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Do you live in Paris now?
并且打扮得光鲜亮丽，其实挺有意思的。在你刚经历完那些之后。我觉得你根本没有运动裤。我有好多运动裤。真的吗？是的，而且我基本上只在现实生活中穿它们，这——我们去年搬去了巴黎，在巴黎你真的不能穿运动裤。你会被驱逐出境的。你的签证会被直接取消。等等，等等，等等，等等。你现在住在巴黎吗？
I live in Paris now, yeah. Wow. Yeah. What a switch. Yeah, it's a really different lifestyle. Now, how many languages do you know? I speak Hebrew and English, obviously English. And my French is like fine.
我现在住在巴黎，是的。哇。是的。真是个巨大的转变。是的，这是一种非常不同的生活方式。那么，你会几种语言？我会希伯来语和英语，显然还有英语。我的法语还行。
Like I can do everything I need to do. It's just not grammatically correct or sophisticated in any way. That's okay. At least they're not judgy. Did you know any of it before you moved there? Yeah, I took it in high school and... But like how many years? I took it in high school too, but I can't...
就像我能做我需要做的所有事情。只是在语法上不太正确，也没有任何高雅可言。没关系。至少他们不势利。你在搬去那里之前就会法语吗？是的，我在高中学过，而且……但学了几年？我也在高中学过，但我不会……
Yeah, I took it like four years. Well, that's good. Yeah. You didn't do it like I did where you take French one and French two twice. Because the first time you took them, it didn't count towards your credits. And then I was like,
对，我学了大概四年。哦，那挺好的。是的。你可不像我那样，法语一和法语二重复上了两遍。因为你第一次上的时候，它不算学分。然后我就在想，
oh, you know what, now that it's credits, I'll just take the two years that I already know so that my class is easy. That's... A dumb guy. That's smart. Yeah. It's a complicated language.
哦，你知道吗，既然现在算学分了，我就把我已经懂的那两年再上一次，这样我的课就轻松了。那是……一个笨蛋。这很聪明。是的。这是一门复杂的语言。
It is. Why... Will, you know it fluently, don't you? I do speak a lot of French, yeah. But I don't want to... Listen, I'm not... It's not here for me to show off. Ask her a question in French.
确实如此。为什么……威尔，你法语说得很流利，对吧？我的确会说很多法语，是的。但我不想……听着，我不是……我不是为了显摆才来这里的。用法语问她一个问题。
No, no, no. Yeah, I want to hear that. Let's hear it. Hello. Yeah, I want to hear that. Let's hear it. So you live in Paris? Oh, I live in the 7th. Oh, okay. She lives in the 7th.
不，不，不。是的，我想听听。我们听听看。哈啰。是的，我想听听。我们听听看。所以你住在巴黎？哦，我住在第七区。哦，好吧。她住在第七区。
She lives in the 7th. Yes. But when you come back to LA, do you love LA? Because I feel like I don't love LA when I'm here, but when I come back here, I'm like, oh, I'm just used to it here. I'm used to a good thing here, and I'm reminded how much I really do enjoy this city. I do love LA.
她住在第七区。是的。但当你回到洛杉矶时，你喜欢洛杉矶吗？因为我觉得我在这里的时候并不觉得有多爱洛杉矶，但当我回到这里时，我会想，哦，我已经习惯这里了。我习惯了这里的美好，并且它提醒着我我是多么真正地享受这座城市。我确实很喜欢洛杉矶。
I mean, I love LA because I feel like you discover it. You know, like there's, it's not an obvious city. Yeah, because you're always driving. Yeah, but like you have to like find the good stuff. You know, like a city like Paris or New York like announces itself like you can just, here you've got to kind of like search and find the good, good interesting stuff.
我的意思是，我喜欢洛杉矶是因为我觉得你需要去发现它。你知道的，就像，它不是一个一眼就能看出来的城市。是的，因为你总是在开车。是的，但你必须去寻找那些好东西。你知道的，像巴黎或纽约这样的城市，它们会自我展现，你可以直接——而在这里，你得去搜寻并发现那些好东西、有趣的东西。
And there's lots of it. You're like, oh, I've been driving by that cool little restaurant my whole life and I never stopped. Yeah, have you ever been to the Huntington Gardens in Pasadena? I was there yesterday. You're kidding. Don't you love that place? My favorite place in the city. Yeah, have you ever been to the Huntington Gardens in Pasadena? I was there yesterday. You're kidding.
而且有很多。你会想，哦，我这辈子一直开车路过那家酷炫的小餐厅，却从来没有停下来过。是的，你去过帕萨迪纳的亨廷顿花园吗？我昨天刚去过。你在开玩笑吧。你不喜欢那个地方吗？那是全城我最喜欢的地方。是的，你去过帕萨迪纳的亨廷顿花园吗？我昨天刚去过。你在开玩笑吧。
Don't you love that place? My favorite place in the city. Yeah, mine too. Wait, I've never been. Will you guys take me? Yeah. And I'm kind of a garden nut. You've never been?
你不喜欢那个地方吗？那是全城我最喜欢的地方。是的，我也是。等等，我从来没去过。你们带我去好吗？好啊。而且我算是个园艺狂热爱好者。你从来没去过？
Oh my God, Jay, I'll tell you how. That's so exciting. Yeah. You're going to have like the best discovery. Wait, don't you think that's weird that you just said that and I brought up the garden nut? That's wild. Jay, don't sell yourself short. You're not a garden nut. You're just a nut. Yeah think that's weird that you just said that and I brought up the girl. Hey, don't sell yourself short You're not a gardener. You're just a no. Yeah, that's true many different nuts
哦，天哪，杰伊，我跟你讲怎么去。太令人兴奋了。是的。你会有一种超棒的发现感。等等，你不觉得奇怪吗？你刚才这么说了，然后我就提到了园艺狂热爱好者？这太疯狂了。杰伊，别妄自菲薄。你不是园艺狂热爱好者。你只是个狂热分子。是的，不觉得奇怪吗？你刚才这么说了，然后我就提到了……嘿，别妄自菲薄。你不是园艺狂热爱好者。你只是个狂热分子。是的，确实有很多不同的狂热分子。
But what do they have beautiful do they have a Japanese garden there because I may have been there to look at that They do and we what's the no truly because there was a moment where I was Into a Japanese garden that I went to go look at a few. And there's one at UCLA I went and looked at. And then maybe there's, maybe it was a Huntington Gardens the other one. What's the Chris Farley Beverly Hills Ninja? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Remember that?
但它们有什么美丽的呢？那里有日式庭院吗？因为我可能去那里看过那个。有的，而且我们——真正的原因是，曾经有一段时间我对日式庭院很感兴趣，于是我去看了几个。加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）有一个，我去看了。然后可能还有，也许另一个是亨廷顿花园。克里斯·法利演的《比佛利山忍者》是哪一部？是的，是的，是的，是的。还记得那个吗？
Yeah, sure. Shot at the Japanese garden when they go to Japan. Oh really? It's just the Huntington Gardens. I know, wait, Nina. It's the best. I know, wait. Oh my God, look at wait. It's important.
当然记得。他们去日本时就是在日式庭院拍的。哦，真的吗？那就是亨廷顿花园。我知道，等等，妮娜。那是最好的。我知道，等等。哦，天哪，看——等等。这很重要。
Maybe I have a rewatch before you go to the visit. I will. I'll brush up. Natalie, I sometimes go there alone just because I love it. I love walking around. It's the best place in the city. I know. There's so much. The desert garden is like walking on the moon.
也许你在去参观之前应该重温一下。我会的。我会复习一下的。娜塔莉，我有时会独自去那里，就因为我太喜欢了。我喜欢到处走走。那是城里最好的地方。我知道。有太多东西了。沙漠花园就像走在月球上一样。
And then you know what I do afterwards? I go to the pie and burger for a burger and a piece of pie. Clutter. Good, what if you blocks away? Call me before you do these semi-suicidal walkabouts. You know, I'll walk with you. Okay, come on, I'd love it, I would love it. It's so peaceful and beautiful.
然后你知道我之后会做什么吗？我去Pie & Burger吃个汉堡和一块派。杂乱。太棒了，离那儿几个街区？你在进行这种半自杀式的散步之前先打个电话给我。你知道的，我会陪你一起走的。行啊，来吧，我很乐意，我非常乐意。那里太宁静美观了。
Sean, what do you think about? What do I think about what? You know, when you're walking through the garden, what do you usually have on the burger? What's running through your mouth? What kind of pie? What is your go-to pie, Johnny? I think about what? When you're walking through the garden. What you're going to have on the burger? What is your go-to pie, Shawnee? I think about Natalie Portman. I think about what she's doing right now.
肖恩，你怎么看？我怎么看什么？你知道的，当你穿过花园时，你通常在汉堡上加什么？你嘴里在琢磨什么？什么派？你最常点什么派，肖妮？我怎么看什么？当你穿过花园时。你打算在汉堡上加什么？你最常点什么派，肖妮？我脑子里想着娜塔莉·波特曼。我在想她现在在做什么。
We should do this together. Yeah, I would love it. I would love to. How great would it be to be walking in the Japanese garden and running to Shawnee and Natalie? Walking. Holding hands, walking through the Japanese garden. I would look around for wear as a camera.
我们应该一起去。是的，我很乐意。我很乐意去。在日式庭院里散步，然后偶遇肖妮和娜塔莉，那该有多棒啊。散步。手拉手走过日式庭院。我会四处张望看看摄像机在哪里。
What are you guys shooting? Yeah, right, sure. All right, Natalie, let's get into the teeth of this interview here. God, it's going to be hard hitting. Let's see here. It's all out of the Wikipedia. No, what, what, what, what, because mom nor dad were into the business, right? No, dad's a fertility doctor.
你们在拍什么呢？是的，没错，当然。好吧，娜塔莉，我们进入这次采访的核心部分吧。天哪，这将会是个犀利的问题。我们来看看。这全都是维基百科上的。不，为什么、为什么、为什么，因为你父母都不是这行的人，对吧？没有，我爸爸是个生殖科医生。
Oh, yeah, yeah. Mom's a painter. Right. Did you see our father? No. Uh-oh. Is that like one of those bad fertility doctors? It sounds like that. Oh, no. That's not your dad. I'm just saying. It's really interesting documentary. I remember there was a TV movie when I was little where everyone they realized that the fertility doctor was like
哦，对，对。妈妈是个画家。没错。你看过我们的父亲吗？没有。哦哦。那是那种庸医劣质生殖科医生吗？听起来是这样。哦，不。那不是你爸爸。我只是随口说说。那是个非常有趣的纪录片。我记得我小时候有一部电视电影，每个人都意识到那个生殖科医生是个……
Messed up because everyone had the eye patches at the playground Yeah, I think you realized that there was like no one one genetic donor for all of the children in the neighborhood Yeah, all the kids had eye patches Nightmare So all the kids had eye patches. Oh. Yes. I do, yeah. Nightmare. Wow. So what was it? Was it, well, wait, so you're reminding your own business,
一团糟，因为游乐场上的每个人都戴着眼罩。是的，我想你意识到社区里所有的孩子只有一个基因捐赠者。是的，所有的孩子都戴着眼罩。噩梦。所以所有的孩子都戴着眼罩。哦。是的，我是。噩梦。哇。那是什么？那是，好吧，等等，所以你在忙你自己的事。
somebody saw you in a store or something. They said, hey, do you want to be a kid model? You were like, no, but you did think, well, maybe I'll go get an agent and start doing commercials, maybe? Jason, you know so much about me. But that's not accurate, right? It's like kind of I'm around the facts,
有人在商店之类的地方看见了你。他们说，嘿，你想当童模吗？你当时说，不，但你确实在想，嗯，也许我该去找个经纪人开始拍广告，也许吧？杰森，你对我的了解可真多。但那并不准确，对吧？就好像我沾了点边，
but not really nailing them. Yeah, no, I really liked them. I was 10 years old. Yes. And I like, I'm from Long Island. I'm from the real Long Island. I'm not out there where all you elites are. I never went to the Hamptons until I was like 35.
但没有真正说中。对，不，我真的很喜欢。我当时10岁。是的。而且我，我是长岛人。我是真正的长岛人。我可不住在你们那些精英呆的地方。我直到大概35岁才去过汉普顿。
Me neither. Johnny Range Rover. Me neither. By the way, for what it's worth. I grew up in like the mall. Yeah. And yeah, a lot of kids I grew up with were like auditioning and doing commercials
我也没有。约翰尼·路虎。我也没有。顺便说一句，不管这有没有价值。我基本上是在商场里长大的。对。而且，是的，和我一起长大的很多孩子都在试镜、拍广告
and stuff to make money for college. And I told my parents like, I'm gonna do that too. And they were very reluctant because they are just like, you know, kids who are actors end up in- Like Jason. Robin liquor stores. Yeah, like me.
之类的事情，为了赚大学学费。我告诉父母我也想这么做。他们非常勉强，因为他们觉得，你知道的，当演员的孩子最后都会——像杰森一样。抢劫酒类商店。对，就像我一样。
End up in trouble. Yeah, look at it. With a golf addiction. And yeah, and I convinced them to let me, and then they let me in. But it was purely to finance a future education. Like it wasn't, you didn't have like some like- Not even, it was just because I wanted to. I mean, my dad, my dad like insisted on paying for my college and stuff anyway, so it was
最后惹上麻烦。对，瞧瞧。有高尔夫球瘾。而且，是的，我说服他们让我去，然后他们就同意了。但纯粹是为了资助未来的教育。这并不是说，你没有什么——甚至都不是，纯粹是因为我想去。我的意思是，反正我爸坚持要为我的大学付学费之类的，所以
just really fun for me. And yeah. And did you start selling cereal? I never got commercials. I always tried out. Really? But I never got anything of the children's things. I just got straight into the professional. That was number one.
对我来说真的很好玩。然后，是的。你开始卖麦片了吗？我从来没接过广告。我总是去试镜。真的吗？但我从来没得到过任何儿童片约。我直接进入了专业领域。那是第一部。
And that was Luc Bason, right? Wait, was that your first job? That was my first job. That was my first job. That was my first job. No way. Yeah. I did one. I was an understudy in an off-Broadway musical
那是吕克·贝松的电影，对吧？等等，那是你的第一份工作？那是我的第一份工作。那是我的第一份工作。那是我的第一份工作。真的假的？对。我做过一次。我是百老汇场外音乐剧的候补演员
before that. That was my one thing. It's called Ruthless. Wait, and you want to know who else was cast as the understudy in that? Lindsay Lohan. No. Correct?
在那之前。那是我的第一份经历。剧名叫《冷酷无情》。等等，你想知道谁也被选为那部剧的候补演员吗？林赛·罗韩。不对。对吗？
No, your close. Sorry, Britney Spears. Britney Spears. Britney Spears was the under, understudy in that? Lindsay Lohan. No. Correct? No, wait. Sorry, Britney Spears. Britney Spears. Britney Spears was the under, I took over for her. No way. When I was 10. Wow.
不对，你猜得很接近。抱歉，布兰妮·斯皮尔斯。布兰妮·斯皮尔斯。布兰妮·斯皮尔斯是那部剧的候补、候补演员？林赛·罗韩。不对。对吗？不对，等等。抱歉，布兰妮·斯皮尔斯。布兰妮·斯皮尔斯。布兰妮·斯皮尔斯是候补，我接替了她的位置。真的假的？在我10岁的时候。哇。
And then I got, yeah. That's crazy. I didn't know that. Have you seen her since? So wait, so you were 11 when you did the professional? I was 11. I turned 12 while we were shooting. Oh my God.
然后我得到了，是的。太疯狂了。我不知道这件事。你后来见过她吗？所以等等，你拍那部专业电影时11岁？我11岁。我们在拍摄的时候我过了12岁生日。我的天哪。
That is so crazy. So you've seen Britney Spears since? Yes. Yes. And you guys did a little high five about, look how far we were shooting. Oh, my God. That is so crazy. So you've seen Britney Spears since? Yes. Yes. And you guys did a little high-five about, look how far we've come. We did. We did. We threw New Year's party together when we were 18. No way. Oh, wow. That's cool.
太疯狂了。所以你后来见过布兰妮·斯皮尔斯？是的。是的。你们俩还击了个掌，庆祝——看看我们走过了多远。天哪。太疯狂了。所以你后来见过布兰妮·斯皮尔斯？是的。是的。你们俩还击了个掌，庆祝——看看我们走过了多远。我们确实拍了。我们确实拍了。我们18岁时一起办过新年派对。真的假的？哦，哇。太酷了。
Yes, way. Hang on a second. That sounds like a good party. It was a good party. You guys at 18 must have been like... Maybe 99. 1999. It must have been like... Maybe 99? 1999? It must have been an enormous party. Was it huge, that party?
千真万确。等一下。听起来是个很棒的派对。确实是个好派对。你们18岁的时候一定……大概99年。1999年。那一定……大概99年吧？1999年？那一定是个规模巨大的派对。那个派对很大吗？
It was a good party. What month? What month was it? What month's your birthday? Oh, my birthday is June. June, what? I thought you were asking what month they had their New Year's party in. Oh, it was New Year's.
是个好派对。哪个月？那是哪个月？你的生日是哪个月？哦，我的生日是六月。六月几号？我还以为你问他们的新年派对是哪个月。哦，那是新年。
Oh, it was New Year's. I thought you said it was birthday party. It was a New Year's party? It was a New Year's party. Okay, so was New Year's. Oh, it was New Year's. I thought you said it was birthday party. It was a New Year's party? It was a New Year's party. Okay, so 99, okay. I used to love throwing parties. God damn it. Right, remember parties?
哦，那是新年。我还以为你说那是生日派对。那是新年派对？那是新年派对。好吧，那是99年，好吧。我以前很喜欢办派对。该死的。对，还记得派对吗？
Remember when we used to throw parties? Now the only parties you throw is for the kids. Yep. That's it. Bouncy houses. Yeah. Yeah, snacks. Were you worried at all when you became a young actor
还记得我们以前办派对的时候吗？现在你办的唯一的派对都是给小孩子办的。没错。就这样。充气城堡。对。对，零食。当你成为一名年轻演员时，你有没有感到过担心
and you're doing the professional, your first film job, which is insane, still insane to me? Were you worried that you're doing the professional, your first film job, which is still insane to me. Were you worried that you would end up, were your parents worried that you'd end up like on a camping trip on mountain bikes with Leaf Garrett? Like did that ever like, was that a concern for you? Like that would be- He's taking a shot at my trajectory.
你在拍《这个杀手不太冷》，你的第一部电影工作，这简直太疯狂了，对我来说现在依然很疯狂？你担不担心自己会落得——你父母担不担心你会落得像莱弗·加利特那样去山地车露营旅行？这种事以前发生过吗——这曾是你们的一个担忧吗？就好像会——他在拿我的演艺生涯开涮。
But by the way, that was a fun trip. It was a fun trip. I know. But no, but were your parents legitimately worried? Did they think like, oh, this is gonna peel you away from work, from school? I'd rather, I mean, not work, but from school and that kind of thing.
但顺便说一句，那是一次有趣的旅行。那是一次有趣的旅行。我知道。但是，不，但是你的父母真的担心吗？他们是不是觉得，哦，这会把你从工作、从学校里拉开？我宁愿，我是说，不是工作，而是从学校和诸如此类的事情中拉开。
Is that what it was? Oh yeah. Yeah, I mean, they were very concerned. They would, I mean, my mom was like with me all the time and made sure that no one got near me. And yeah, and I wasn't allowed to miss school. So I always was shooting on like vacations. And then yeah, when I went to college, my dad was like,
是这样吗？哦，是的。是的，我的意思是，他们非常担心。他们会，我的意思是，我妈一直陪着我，确保任何人都不敢靠近我。而且，是的，我不被允许逃学。所以我总是在假期拍戏。然后，是的，当我上大学时，我爸就说，
okay, that was cute. Time to move on. Really? Let's find another job, a real job. And then when you majored in psychology, was that because that was the occupation that you wanted to go into? Or was it just like, no, this is something that I'm interested in?
好吧，那挺可爱的。是时候前进了。真的吗？去找另一份工作，一份真正的工作。然后当你主修心理学时，是因为那是你想从事的职业吗？还是只是觉得，不，这是我感兴趣的东西？
Yeah, I feel like it was more like most people who study psychology, which is like, I wanna know why I'm crazy. Yeah, so I'm fascinated by it. I wish I'd studied that. Yeah. I'd have some answers. I don't know, but don't you think like,
对，我觉得这更像是大多数学习心理学的人的心态，那就是：“我想知道我为什么会发疯。”是的，所以我对此很着迷。我真希望我也学过这个。对。那样我就会有一些答案了。我不知道，但你不觉得，
acting in the thing that we do is kind of a form of psychology? And... Totally. You know, because it's the study of human behavior, that's all we do. It is very similar. Did you have a specific role model, mentor ideal when you did take the time off kind of when you went to school?
演戏和我们做的事情其实也是心理学的一种形式吗？而且……完全是。你知道的，因为那是对人类行为的研究，这就是我们所做的一切。这非常相似。当你为了上学而暂停演艺事业时，你有没有一个特定的榜样、导师或理想对象？
And the one that comes to mind potentially is Jodie Foster. Yeah. Yeah? Yeah, Jodie Foster was definitely. You know, I talked to her much later, which was amazing. I did a speech at a women's march about being like sexualized as a young actress and she reached out to me after that and we like talked and it was amazing and she's just, she's, yeah, she's still a role model. But she's pretty cool. Yeah. And now are you,
脑海中浮现的潜在人选可能是朱迪·福斯特。对。是吗？对，朱迪·福斯特绝对算一个。你知道的，我很久以后和她聊过，这太棒了。我在一次妇女游行中发表过关于年轻女演员被性客化的演讲，她在那之后联系了我，我们聊了聊，感觉太棒了。她就是，她，是的，她仍然是我的榜样。但她真的很酷。对。现在，
are you also like just going back to the whole comment that you said about this, being sexualized as a young actress and how awful that must be. Do you now have all these years having worked in the business, do you recognize a personality when they walk into the room as a dangerous one now that you have been around it for so long? You're like, you know what, I can see that man or woman coming towards me or we're gonna work together or maybe something else.
你是不是也——回到你刚才说的那个评论，关于作为年轻女演员被性客化以及那有多糟糕。在这行工作了这么多年后，既然你在这一行呆了这么久，当一个具有危险性格的人走进房间时，你能认出来吗？你会想，你知道吗，我能看到那个男人或女人向我走来，我们要一起工作，或者可能会发生点别的。
And you recognize it so you've learned to adjust or how to deal with that? No, no, I haven't. It's perfect. I feel like it's still surprising that it exists. Yeah. Yeah, but I feel like that kind of like projection of seriousness protected me in a way But yeah, but I feel like that kind of like projection
你能认出来，所以你学会了调整自己或如何应对吗？不，不，我没有。太完美了。我觉得它存在这本身依然让人感到惊讶。对。是的，但我感觉那种——表现出的严肃态度在某种程度上保护了我。但是，是的，但我感觉那种——表现出的严肃态度
of seriousness protected me in a way because I feel like it was almost like a warning signal, like, oh, don't do shit to her. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yes, she'll sniff you out and call you out. Not that anyone ever like, you know, deserves it or is asking for it, but like you can, you know, I felt like that was my,
在某种程度上保护了我，因为我觉得这几乎就像是一个警告信号，就像是，“哦，别对她搞什么阴招。”对，对，对，对。是的，她会看穿你并当众揭穿你。并不是说真的有人，你知道的，罪有应得或者自找麻烦，但你可以，你知道的，我觉得那是我的，
my conscious way, unconscious way of doing it. But with people, yeah, I feel like the biggest sign is when people talk shit about women. I'm like, if they talk shit about anyone, even if they're just like, oh, she's really difficult, or she's, I'm like, that's like a flag for me. I'm like, there's more to that story.
我有意识或无意识的做法。但对于人际关系，是的，我觉得最大的标志就是当人们说女性的坏话时。我会想，如果他们说任何人的坏话，哪怕他们只是说，“哦，她很难搞，”或者她怎么怎么样，我就会想，这对我来说是个危险信号。我会想，事情没那么简单。
I'm like, there's a place in it. And when I walk away, what are they gonna say about me? Yeah, like there's, yeah, talking shit in general. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor. Thanks to ZipRecruiter for their support. Our friends at ZipRecruiter conducted a recent survey and found that the top hiring challenge
我会想，这里面有蹊跷。当我走开时，他们会怎么说我？是的，就像，是的，背后说人坏话总体来说就是这样。是的，这说得通。对。现在，听一段我们赞助商的广告。感谢 ZipRecruiter 的支持。我们的朋友 ZipRecruiter 最近进行了一项调查，发现雇主在
employers face for 2024 is a lack of qualified candidates. But if you're an employer and need to hire, here's good news. ZipRecruiter has smart tools and features that help you find more qualified candidates fast and right now you can try it for free at zippercrootter.com slash smartless. All you need to do is post your job and Zipper Crootter's powerful matching technology shows you candidates whose experience match it. You can even use their invite to apply feature to encourage top candidates to respond to your job post. Let me tell you, if I'm looking to hire right now, I'm looking no further than Zippercruiter. True story.
2024 年面临的最大招聘挑战是缺乏合格的候选人。但如果你是一名雇主并且需要招聘，好消息来了。ZipRecruiter 拥有智能工具和功能，可以帮助你快速找到更多合格的候选人，现在你可以在 zippercruiter.com/smartless 上免费试用。你所需要做的就是发布你的职位，ZipRecruiter 强大的匹配技术就会向你展示工作经验与之相匹配的候选人。你甚至可以使用他们的“一键邀请申请”功能来鼓励顶级候选人回复你的职位发布。实话告诉你，如果我现在想招聘，我只会找 ZipRecruiter。千真万确。
Let Zippercruiter help you conquer the biggest hiring challenge, finding qualified candidates. See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to try ZipRecruiter for free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. SMARTLESS. and the best of what you love or something new to discover. There are many wellness categories for you to choose from on Audible,
让 ZipRecruiter 帮你克服最大的招聘挑战：找到合格的候选人。看看为什么五分之四在 ZipRecruiter 上发布职位的雇主在第一天就能找到高质量的候选人。现在就访问这个专属网址免费试用 ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再次强调，网址是 ZipRecruiter.com/S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。SMARTLESS。以及你最喜欢的内容或有待发掘的新事物。Audible 上有许多健康类别供你选择，
such as physical, mental, spiritual, social, motivational, occupational, and financial wellness. You'll find voices that'll motivate you to take action or sounds to soothe, to help you focus, reduce stress, and sleep better. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases.
例如身体、心理、精神、社交、励志、职业和财务健康。你会在这里找到能激励你采取行动的声音，或者能舒缓身心、帮你专注、减轻压力并改善睡眠的声音。作为 Audible 会员，你可以从整个目录中每月挑选一本图书永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新发布的作品。
I just started, how am I gonna say this? The subtle art of not giving a fuck. Eek. And obviously the beep is longer than the two letters that it's replacing in between, but it's or three because I the C as well so it's it was you CK in case you didn't know anyway I'm listening to that on audible and it is absolutely fantastic because not only do I like to read books, when I'm not reading, I like to listen to books. Guys, I'm very popular.
我刚开始听，我该怎么说呢？《不羁的艺术》（The subtle art of not giving a fuck）。额。显然，哔哔声比它中间替代的那两个字母要长，或者说是三个字母，因为我也把字母 C 删掉了，所以它是 U-C-K，以防你不知道。总之我在 Audible 上听这本书，它绝对太棒了，因为我不但喜欢看书，
Anyway, as an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartLess to 500 500 that's audible.com slash smartLess or text smartLess to 500 500 to try audible free for 30 days. Be sure to visit our
不看书的时候，我还喜欢听书。伙计们，我很受欢迎。总之，作为 Audible 会员，你可以从整个目录中每月挑选一本图书永久保留。新会员可以免费试用 Audible 30 天。访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500。网址是 audible.com/smartless，或者发送短信 smartLess 到 500-500，网址是 audible.com/smartLess，或者发送短信 smartLess 到 500-500，即可免费试用 Audible 30 天。请务必访问我们的
URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartLess. All right back to the show. You want to get to Star Wars, Sean? No, I'm not going to go on her. I was going to apologize, but in advance, and then say, Manley, we're really sorry, but Sean has some shit that he needs to do for us. No, no, that's okay. It has to do with the planet Voltron or whatever.
网址，好让他们知道是我们介绍你来的：audible.com/smartLess。好的，言归正传。你想聊聊《星球大战》吗，肖恩？不，我不会把话题扯到她身上。我本想提前道个歉，然后说，曼利，我们真的很抱歉，但肖恩有些工作需要为我们处理。不，不，没关系。这跟伏特龙星球或者别的什么有关。
No, no, no. You know how much I love you and I loved everything you've done. But so I just, I just will say like a blanket statement about Star Wars and the Marvel universe and any kind of big movie that you're a part of are deep because I grew up in Chicago with like big dreams of like going out to LA and being, you know, working as an actor.
不，不，不。你知道我多爱你，也知道我多喜欢你做过的一切。但我只想就《星球大战》、漫威宇宙以及你参与过的任何大型电影发表一个宽泛的声明，因为我是带着去洛杉矶并成为一名演员的巨大梦想在芝加哥长大的。
And so you get here and I still have that awe of like, oh my God, I can't believe I'm on a lot. I can't believe I'm on a set. It never goes away. And so my question to you is like having grown up in it and Jason too, when you're a part of Star Wars or the Marvel Universe or whatever it is, are you still at all, like me, the little kid from Chicago,
所以你来到了这里，我依然对“天哪，我不敢相信我在片场里。我不敢相信我在拍戏”这种事充满敬畏。这种感觉从未消退。所以我对你的问题是，既然你也是在这样的环境中长大，杰森也是，当你参与《星球大战》或漫威宇宙或任何此类作品时，你是否还像我一样，像那个来自芝加哥的小孩那样，
is like, I can't believe it? Or are you just like, I got this job, here's the work, I'm gonna show up on time and do my job. Do you know what I mean? Can you separate it at all? Or are you still in awe? I'm pretty in awe. Like when I got to,
会觉得“我真不敢相信”？还是会觉得“我接下了这份工作，这就是任务，我要按时出现并做好我的工作”？你知道我的意思吗？你完全能把它们分得清吗？还是你仍然感到敬畏？我还是挺敬畏的。比如当我到——
I feel like it was luckier to do the last Thor because it was, like I have done so much now that I can understand how different it is. Like the technology and stuff makes me amazed, and also having kids now, getting to bring my kids to the set, and like, you know, they get to fly on wires, and watch me fly, and I have a 12 year old and a 30 year old.
我觉得拍最后一部《雷神》时更幸运，因为——我现在已经拍了足够多的戏，所以我能理解它们有多么不同。比如技术之类的东西让我感到惊叹，而且现在有了孩子，能把我的孩子们带到片场，然后，你知道的，他们有机会吊威亚，看着我飞，我有一个12岁的和一个30岁的——
30 and 40, I'm kidding. 12 and six, is that what you said? Perfect, love it. Yeah, so now they're starting to, well, does that, do you think about them when you consider parts too? Like, oh, this one I'm gonna get major cred for them. Oh, yeah, oh yeah. Like, main consideration is what they'll think.
30岁和40岁，我开玩笑呢。12岁和6岁，你是这么说的吗？太完美了，我喜欢。是的，所以现在他们开始——等一下，你在考虑角色时也会考虑到他们吗？比如，“哦，这个角色会让他们对我刮目相看。”哦，会啊，哦，会啊。主要的考量就是他们的看法。
Yeah. Was there, who in the room at the Globes do you think a selfie with, would have given you the best points with your 12 year old? I mean, would have been Taylor? No, my 12 year old's a boy. Unlike, there were no soccer players in that room, so. Is he's a big soccer fan?
是的。在金球奖的现场，你觉得跟谁合影能让你的12岁儿子对你佩服得五体投地？我的意思是，会是泰勒吗？不，我12岁儿子是个男孩。不像，那个房间里没有足球运动员，所以。他是超级球迷吗？
Oh, Matt. And you know, who's his team? Hang on, who's his team? Hang on, who's his team? He loves Real Madrid and he loves Arsenal. Really? And PSG, of course. Of course, PSG, sure.
哦，马特。你知道的，他支持哪支球队？等一下，他支持哪支球队？等一下，他支持哪支球队？他喜欢皇家马德里，他也喜欢阿森纳。真的吗？还有巴黎圣日耳曼，当然。当然，巴黎圣日耳曼，肯定的。
And he loves him. And Boppe might go to Real Madrid. And the Red Angels City here, of course. Sure, sure. Oh, right. Wait, you're part of Angel City. He's a part owner and a soccer team, Willie. Yes, I know that.
而且他超喜欢他。姆巴佩可能会去皇马。还有本地的红天使队，当然。肯定的，肯定的。哦，对了。等等，你是天使队的一员。你是女足俱乐部的联合老板，威利。是的，我知道。
That's right. Women's soccer, right? Yes. You're right, women's soccer, right? I'm a huge, yes. You're a huge soccer fan? Massive, I'm a massive Liverpool supporter. A Liverpool. Yeah, yeah, yeah, and I watch every, but there's talk, I don't wanna get into Mbappe, maybe go to Liverpool or Real Madrid. Is that right?
没错。女子足球，对吧？是的。没错，女子足球，对吧？我是个超级——是的。你是超级足球迷？巨大，我是利物浦的超级死忠。利物浦的。对，对，对，我看每一场，但有传言，我不想扯到姆巴佩身上，他可能会去利物浦或皇马。是这样吗？
Yeah, yeah, that's what the word is yesterday, according to Sky Sports. Oh man. Hope not, hope not for us in Paris. I'm like your 12 year old. Like I, for me, it's about athletes. Like if you meet all these people, but then you see an athlete and you're like, oh my God.
对，对，昨天天空体育就是这么说的。天哪。希望不要，对我们在巴黎的球迷来说希望不要。我跟你12岁的儿子一样。对我来说，关键在于运动员。就像如果你遇到了所有这些人，但接着你看到了一位运动员，你就会想，天哪。
Oh my God, I don't want to talk loud. What would I say if you talked to me? How will I, you know, I got to meet Jurgen Klopp, who's the manager of Liverpool and I nearly cried. That was recent too, and I nearly cried. That was recent too, and I'm over 50. I got like that at the Globes. I was like, you know, all those famous people and there's Neil Katyal, who's like,
天哪，我都不敢大声说话。如果我跟他说话，我会说些什么？我该怎么，你知道的，我曾有机会见到尤尔根·克洛普，利物浦的主教练，我差点哭了。那也是不久前的事，我差点哭了。那也是不久前的事，而我都年过五十了。我在金球奖上也有过这种感觉。我就像，你知道的，那些名人都在那儿，还有尼尔·卡蒂亚尔（Neil Katyal），他就像——
who's our old solicitor general, right? I got as tongue-tied as I am right now, talking to him. Who is that? He's just, he's a, he's a, he's a, just a real smart lawyer that is on MSNBC. He's argued lots of big cases in front of the Supreme Court. Yeah, that's really cool. I could style those people for hours.
他是我们的前副总检察长，对吧？我跟他说起话来结结巴巴的，就像我现在这样。那是谁？他只是一个，一个，一个，一个在 MSNBC 上很聪明的律师。他在最高法院前辩论过许多重大案件。是的，这真的很酷。我可以跟那些人聊好几个小时。
And it's all I wanted to talk to. Okay. Yeah. All right. Moving on. Oh, but, but you will be excited about this Star Wars story from the Globes. I met Mark Hamill for my first time. For the first time?
这也是我唯一想聊的。好吧。好的。继续。哦，但是，但是你听到这个关于金球奖的《星球大战》故事一定会很兴奋。我生平第一次见到了马克·哈米尔。生平第一次？
As a Globes. Are you kidding me? No way. And he called me his mother. He was my son. Wait a minute. So, but you meet my mother, finally. Wow.
在金球奖上。你在开玩笑吧？怎么可能。他叫我他的母亲。我是他的儿子。等一下。所以，但你终于见到我母亲了。哇。
Wait, I can't believe you didn't meet him before that. Never. But why? Wouldn't he have been like a consultant on Phantom Menace and all those other ones? No, they never brought him around. And I never would have known. Did somebody get a photo of that?
等等，我不敢相信你之前没见过他。从来没有。但为什么？难道他不是《幽灵的威胁》和其他那些电影的顾问吗？不，他们从来没带他来过。而且我永远也不会知道。有人拍下那张照片了吗？
We got a photo. His daughter took a picture of us together. That's a no way. Oh shit. Shit, I gotta get that. That's her next appointment. Yo. That's crazy that she met him for the first time. Yeah, I wonder if anybody...
我们拍了张照片。他女儿给我们拍了合照。真的假的？哦，靠。靠，我得把那张照片弄到手。这是她下一个预约。哟。她生平第一次见到他，这太疯狂了。对啊，我在想是不是有人……
Oh, I wonder if you... Uh, add to the report signature. Okay. This is... It's a UPS delivery, guys. And do you tell him to just leave it there? Or did you just... I think they can just leave it.
哦，我在想你……呃，在报告签名上添上一笔。好吧。这是……这是UPS的快递，伙计们。你告诉他直接放在那儿就行？还是你直接……我觉得他们可以直接放下。
This is a sign only. Okay. All right, so then you met Mark Hamill. I think I was like, hello, men, men, we're here with your cannabis. We have the whole truck. Where do you want us to put it? Your high powered weed, your stinky butt is here.
这是需要本人签收的。好吧。好吧，所以你遇到了马克·哈米尔。我想我当时就像是，你好，男士们，男士们，我们带着你们的大麻来了。我们开着整辆卡车。你们想让我们把它放在哪儿？你们的高纯度大麻，你们的臭烘烘的宝贝到了。
Fuck. So no one got a shot of Luke with his mother except... No, they did. Somebody did. No, no, but just Luke's daughter, right? There wasn't like any media that got a shot of that? No media. It was a press-to-film.
操。所以除了……没有其他人拍到卢克和他母亲的合影吗？不，他们拍了。有人拍了。不，不，但只有卢克的女儿拍了，对吧？没有什么媒体拍到那张照片吗？没有媒体。那是私人拍摄。
Wow, that's like a money shot, man. Wow. Now, talk to me about directing. Do you love it as much as acting? Do you love it more, less? I do love it. I think I love both things. And I feel like it changes the way I act after,
哇，那就像是黄金镜头啊，老兄。哇。现在，跟我聊聊导演吧。你喜欢当导演胜过当演员吗？你更喜欢，还是更不喜欢？我确实很喜欢。我觉得这两样我都喜欢。而且我觉得这改变了我之后的表演方式，
yeah, after trying to do more different options. Because I feel like I was always trying to like hone my performance, like do the same thing just better each time. And then when I had to watch myself back in the editing room, I was like, it's the same thing over and over again. I want a choice. So then I was like, so now I try and do different things
是的，在尝试了更多不同的选择之后。因为我觉得我以前总是试图打磨我的表演，每次都做同样的事情但争取做得更好。然后当我在剪辑室里回看自己的表现时，我心想，这不就是一遍又一遍地重复同一件事吗。我想要有选择的余地。所以我当时就想，现在我尝试做不同的事情，
so a director in the editing room can be like. But then you've only got one take of you doing that particular choice. You don't have seven good versions of that choice, you know, that you can play with the editing room, you know? Yeah. I mean, you can try and get that main choice when you get the camera work and acting right. And then...
这样剪辑室里的导演就可以说——但那样的话，你做那个特定选择的镜头就只有一个。你没有那个选择的七个好版本，你知道的，你可以把它们放在剪辑室里把玩，对吧？是的。我的意思是，当你把摄像机位和表演都做对的时候，你可以尽量拍出那个主要的表演选择。然后……
Go ahead again. This is now the code. I forgot to drop off the lighters. We have your lighters. We are here with your lighters. So, um... Let's listen. Somebody come here. Oh, okay. Yeah, go.
继续。现在这是暗号。我忘把打火机拿下来了。我们有你们的打火机。我们带着你们的打火机来了。所以，嗯……听着。有人来这儿了。哦，好吧。对，去吧。
You too. You gotta go side. No. No. It's okay. I called it. This is fantastic. This is the best.
你也是。你得去旁边。不。不。没关系。我叫的。这太棒了。这是最棒的。
This is the best. Hi. Hi. You guys, I need to fix my life. Any pointers? I'll be over at noon. You might need a house manager that can cover IT and deliveries. Great.
这真是太棒了。嗨。嗨。伙计们，我需要整顿一下我的生活。有什么建议吗？我中午过去。你可能需要一个能兼顾IT和快递的房屋经理。太棒了。
Awesome. I like you keeping it real. We love the little pauses. Now listen, speaking of take after take after take, I'm directing it. I made December, you're so brilliant in that movie. And I'm gonna jump all around with the movie because it was fascinating.
棒极了。我喜欢你这么接地气。我们喜欢这些小停顿。现在听着，说到一遍又一遍地拍，我在导演这部电影。我在《五月的十二月》里，你在那部电影里太惊艳了。我要在电影的各个片段间跳跃，因为它太迷人了。
And the very last scene, hopefully spoiler alert, stop listening if you haven't seen the movie, but the very last scene, where you as the actress within the movie, the part doing take after take after take, that was so interesting. So what was going through your mind, that must have been like so surreal for you to have,
而最后一个镜头——希望不算剧透，如果你还没看过这部电影就别听了——但最后一个镜头，你在电影里扮演一个演员，一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地拍戏，那太有趣了。所以你当时脑子里在想什么？对你来说一定非常超现实吧，
what we were just talking about, being a director and an actor and then doing that. Well, it was really, yeah, that last take, I mean, that last scene was really, yeah, that last take, I mean, that last scene was very... I didn't really realize while I was reading it that there was going to be like a 17 year old kid in the scene. All of a sudden, he gets a set and there's this actor and like his mom.
就像我们刚才说的，既当导演又当演员，然后去拍那个。嗯，真的，是的，最后一个镜头，我是说，那场戏真的，是的，最后一个镜头非常……我读剧本时并没有意识到场景里会出现一个17岁的男孩。突然之间他到了片场，还有这个演员以及他的妈妈。
And then there's like a snake, like a real snake. And I was like, didn't think about that either. And I was just like, oh, boy. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So that was written that you do take after take, right? Yeah. Yeah, it was written that way. So that's what I was thinking about.
然后还有一条蛇，一条真蛇。我想，我之前也没想到这一点。我当时就想，天哪。对，对，对。所以剧本里就写了你要一遍又一遍地拍，对吧？对。对，剧本就是这么写的。这就是我当时在想的。
Yeah, yeah. I mean, the whole tone of the movie, too. Like when the first, in the first, I think it was the first music cue, when she goes to the fridge and she opens the door and there's this push in with the music. I was like, wait, what, what's going on? And then you're along for the ride
对，对。我的意思是，整部电影的基调也是如此。比如当第一个，在第一个，我 tror 那是第一个音乐提示时，当她走到冰箱前打开门，伴随着音乐镜头推进。我当时想，等等，什么，发生什么了？然后你就跟着剧情一起体验，
and it was so fantastic. And the one scene that you should win every award for, and I'm sure everybody comments on it, so I'm sorry, is the monologue straight to camera, in one take, it was just a class in like, you know, a master class in acting and the craft and everything, it was just perfection. Is Todd Haynes as stunning as I think he is?
简直太棒了。而且有一场戏你应该赢得所有奖项，我确信每个人都在评论它，所以我很抱歉，就是对着镜头的独白，一镜到底，简直是一堂表演大师课，关于表演、手艺以及一切的教科书，简直完美无瑕。托德·海恩斯（Todd Haynes）像我想象的那么惊艳吗？
I love him, I love him. He's, I mean, like you were saying, the music choice on that refrigerator scene is like so key to let everyone know that it's okay to laugh, you know? Because we're kind of not sure. And then it's such a tension release. And he's just the most brilliant.
我爱死他了，我太爱他了。他，我的意思是，就像你刚才说的，冰箱那场戏的音乐选择简直是点睛之笔，让每个人都知道笑出来是没关系的，你知道吗？因为我们有点不确定。然后那是一种极大的压力释放。他简直是最才华横溢的。
I love him. And he's a really awesome person too. But like think about all the incredible directors that you've worked with. It does set you up to be like an incredible director because you can just cherry pick from all of them and toss out all the stuff that you don't like. Like, it's what I'm amazed more at.
我爱他。而且他也是个非常棒的人。但是想想你合作过的所有不可思议的导演。这确实能让你成为一个出色的导演，因为你可以从他们所有人身上汲取精华，然后扔掉所有你不喜欢的东西。就像，这更让我感到惊叹的是——
Well, you had that too, right? Well, I haven't worked with the level of directors that you have in the day. Your first film you ever did was with Luc Besson. I mean, that's insane. Yeah. I was very lucky. I was very lucky.
嗯，你也有过这种经历，对吧？嗯，我没有合作过像你过去合作过的那种级别的导演。你拍的第一部电影就是和吕克·贝松合作的。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。是的。我真的很幸运。我真的很幸运。
What a way to start. But it's a real time suck and, you know. Directing. Yeah, I mean, you know, he got all the prep, the shooting and the post instead of just the shooting part. So, but, but needless to say, more to come from you with directing? I intend to, yes.
真是个绝佳的起点。但这真的很耗费时间，你知道的。当导演。对，我的意思是，你知道的，他经历了所有的前期筹备、拍摄和后期，而不仅仅是拍摄部分。所以，但是，不用说，你以后还会有更多导演作品吗？我打算这么做，是的。
And yeah, I actively work on it. What about you? I would love to. She's gone. Oh, bye. She's gone. Hey listener. Well, it looks like we lost Natalie for the final time
而且，是的，我正在积极为此努力。你呢？我也很想。她走了。哦，拜拜。她走了。嘿，听众朋友们。嗯，看来我们最后还是失去了娜塔莉，
and we decided that we weren't gonna to call her back. Right, guys? We're not going to torture her anymore. With clearly having some Wi-Fi issues. But we got more than enough from the incredible Natalie Portman. And I mean, she's just amazing. She's a powerhouse. She could do it all.
我们决定不再给她回电话了。对吧，伙计们？我们不会再折磨她了。显然她遇到了一些 Wi-Fi 问题。但我们从了不起的娜塔莉·波特曼那里得到了足够多的料。我的意思是，她太惊艳了。她是个全能强者。她什么都能做。
I mean, I wish she. Oh, wait. She's a mom. She's a powerhouse, she could do it all. I mean, I wish- Oh wait, she's a mom. She's a mom, she's an actor, an activist, a director, a Harvard grad, she's just like the nicest, funniest person. I wish you guys could both work with her. She's such a mega, you know, I use this sometimes. She's one of those people,
我的意思是，我希望她。哦，等等。她是一位母亲。她是个全能强者，她什么都能做。我的意思是，我希望——哦，等一下，她是一位母亲。她是一位母亲，她是一位演员、一位维权人士、一位导演、哈佛毕业生，她简直是最好、最搞笑的人。我希望你们俩都能跟她合作。她是个超级巨星，你知道的，我有时会这么用这个词。她属于那种人，
she falls into the mega talent category. And you know, everything she does, everything, she's never been bad. Never been bad, always been classy. Never gotten all tangled up in the nonsense of this business. No. Which is hard to do.
她落入超级天才的类别。而且你知道，她做的每一件事，每一件事，她从来没有演砸过。从来没演砸过，一直很有格调。从来没有被这个行业乱七八糟的事情缠身。没有。这很难做到。
Don't you think it's weird that she was talking about discovering places in Los Angeles and the one place I say she was just there yesterday? Don't you think that's weird. Yeah. You think she's lying? What? What are you accusing her of?
你不觉得奇怪吗，她刚才在谈论发现洛杉矶的各个地方，而我唯一提到地方她昨天刚去过？你不觉得这很奇怪吗。对。你觉得她在撒谎吗？什么？你在指责她什么？
No, I'm saying like that's so wild that I call that out. I know, I know, I'm just kidding. Of course, yeah. It's bonkers. It's so crazy. So Jay, I'll take you to the Huntington Gardens. You will? You get the sense, Jay.
不，我的意思是，我能说出那个地方太疯狂了。我知道，我知道，我开玩笑呢。当然，是的。这太荒谬了。太疯狂了。所以杰森，我会带你去亨廷顿花园。真的吗？你会有这种感觉，杰森。
You know what I like to is that you get the sense that you're, and you've done an admirable job considering that you've not only grew up doing this stuff, but that you still stayed living here and this was your life and that you ended up quasi normal. And that she's done it in a way that like, she was very insulated by going back to school
你知道我喜欢的是，你会觉得，考虑到你不仅从小就在做这些事情，而且你依然住在这里，这就是你的生活，你最后还变得几乎很正常，你做到了这一点，并且你做得令人钦佩。而且她做这一切的方式是，她通过重返学校受到了很好的保护，
and by continuing with her studies and going to college. And that she seems to have held onto this kind of like, this sort of sane center that she has, that that's what she, you know, she says that she projects like a serious friend. It's not that she projects this person who seems very centered and has a solid. Yeah, she's self-contained.
通过继续学业并上大学。而且她似乎保持了这样一种健康的中心状态，这就是她，你知道的，她说她表现得像一个严肃的朋友。并不是说她刻意表现成这样，而是她看起来非常中心稳固且坚实。对，她是个自给自足的人。
She doesn't seem like she needs anything from this business to become fully formed. When you don't need to be validated by what you do, first of all, we've talked about this before, but certainly by this business, forget any business, but certainly ours, if you need that to make yourself feel better, you're fucked. Yeah, totally fucked.
她看起来不需要从这个行业获得什么来让自己成为一个完整的人。当你不需要通过你做的事情来获得认可时——首先，我们以前讨论过这一点，但绝对不需要通过这个行业，忘掉任何行业吧，但绝对不需要通过我们的行业——如果你需要这些来让自己感觉更好，你就完蛋了。是的，彻底完蛋了。
Anyway, she's one of the great ones. I was wild that she lived in Paris and here, which means she's... Bye. Coastal. Paris, not on a coast, in a different country. Bye, country. Bye, continental. Bye, country.
总之，她是顶尖的那批人之一。我很惊讶她既住在巴黎又住在这里，这意味着她是……拜拜。海岸人。巴黎，不在海岸上，在另一个国家。拜拜，国家。拜拜，大陆人。拜拜，国家。
Smart. Bye! Perry, Rob Armjharve, and Bennett Barbicó. Smart Loss If you like Smart Loss, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wendry.com slash survey. Academy is a new scripted podcast that follows Ava Richards,
聪明。再见！Perry, Rob Armjharve, and Bennett Barbicó. Smart Loss 如果你喜欢 Smart Loss，现在就可以通过加入 Wondry App 或 Apple Podcasts 上的 Wondry Plus 提前收听无广告版。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上收听无广告版。在你离开之前，请在 wendry.com/survey 上填写简短的问卷，向我们介绍一下你自己。《学院》（Academy）是一部全新的剧本化播客，讲述了 HBO《行业风云》主演迈哈拉·赫罗尔德（Myha'la Herrold）饰演的艾娃·理查兹（Ava Richards）的故事。她是一名聪明的奖学金学生，必须迅速适应她新发现的“弱肉强食”的世界。
played by HBO's Industries, Myhalla Harald, a brilliant scholarship student who has to quickly adapt to her new found eat or be eaten world. Ava's ambitions take hold and her small town values break in hopes of becoming the first scholarship student to make
艾娃的野心开始萌芽，为了成为第一个进入“精英榜”的奖学金学生，她打破了小镇价值观。
the list. Bishop Gray is all coveted academic top 10, curated by the headmaster himself. But after realizing she has no chance at the list on her own, she reluctantly accepts an invitation to a secret underground society that pulls the strings on campus life and academic success. If she bends to their will, she'll have everything she's ever dreamed of. But at what cost? Academy takes you into the world of a cutthroat private school where power, money, and sex collide in a game of life and death. Follow Academy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge all episodes of Academy early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“格雷主教学院”备受追捧的学术前十名，由校长亲自评选。但在意识到自己凭一己之力毫无机会进入该榜单后，她勉强接受了一个秘密地下社团的邀请，该社团操纵着校园生活和学业成功。如果她屈服于他们的意愿，她将拥有一切梦寐以求的东西。但代价是什么呢？《学院》将带你进入一个尔虞我诈的私立学校世界，权力、金钱和性在一场生死游戏中交织碰撞。在 Wondry App 或你获取播客的任何地方关注《学院》。通过加入 Wondry Plus，你可以立即提前且无广告地畅听《学院》的所有剧集。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。